[Musique]
d'angély unis ça recommence
20 qui dément son
équipe à la
pause
du confinement contre
les renforts
loupé on m'a mis
pente
bonsoir
chez les français sauf sans doute du
côté de cahors dont vous avez l'accent
on va l'entendre récemment l'ops vous
qualifiez de cerveau gauche de la droite
on va vérifier ça pendant l'heure qui va
suivre vous nous direz si le poids de
l'immigration dans les discours des
candidats et leur est bien calibrée où
sont-ils et morizet si vous me passez
cette expression quel serait le meilleur
pour battre emmanuel macron dans 20
minutes yves thréard sera face à vous
pour ces questions politiques puis vous
débattre et avec deux parlementaires
c'est la spécificité de cette émission
et dans quelques instants évidemment
toutes les questions d'actualité mais
d'abord pour vous situez vous avez 34
ans je crois 5,35 pardon vous avez 35
ans vous n'avez connu que la journée
d'appel j'imagine est connu que le jury
d'appel alors que pensez vous de la
proposition de michel barnier
d'organiser un référendum pour rétablir
le service militaire en france je me
suis personnellement pas favorable pour
deux raisons cela provient parce que
matériellement on sait pas faire
organiser le service militaire il faut
des infrastructures il faut du monde
pour encadrer et la réalité c'est que
maintenant qu'on a déconstruit le
service militaire
le rétablir serait très difficile en
suisse qu'il faut dire aussi c'est que
ma génération nous avons un parcours de
vie y compris professionnelle qui n'est
pas tout à fait celui que l'on avait
lorsque le service militaire existait
encore et aujourd'hui c'est difficile de
consacrer deux années par exemple de sa
vie professionnelle au service militaire
troisièmes réserves c'est que je trouve
qu'il ya une petite illusion selon
laquelle le service militaire était un
outil qui permettait à chacun quel que
soit son origine de rentrer dans le même
dans les mêmes clous la vérité c'est que
sur la fin le système du
d'où l'engagement et
du service militaire pardon était très
inégale ceux qui avaient la facilité de
se faire pistonner pour dire les choses
simplement d'en bénéficier pas et ceux
qui venaient des classes les plus
modestes ont bénéficié bref tout ce
système là n'était pas au goût du jour
en revanche michel barnier a raison de
poser la question de l'engagement de nos
jeunes dans le destin national dans le
récit national et je crois que cette
énergie là on ne l'a consacré à l'école
pour moi c'est l'école qui doit reporter
un discours un discours de la nation
voilà on n'entend pas beaucoup parler
d'école si vous me permettez c'est pour
ça qu'une candidats aient l'air donc en
tout cas merci pour cette première
réponse très claire assez franches on
espère que la suite de l'émission sera
sur le même ton jeu vous présentez vous
les connaissez brigitte boucher
jourdain pour public sénat qui entame
sur la boit de l'eau précisément vie la
guadeloupe est une réunion actuellement
à matignon autour des difficultés ou
plutôt des tensions en cours en
guadeloupe pour l'instant la réponse du
gouvernement elle est surtout
sécuritaire avec l'envoi du gign et duo
red est ce que c'est la bonne méthode
selon nous avons une urgence et un
incendie médias qui est effectivement la
situation sécuritaire on sait désormais
des armes ont été volés auprès des
services de douanes
l'état du territoire et d'un point de
vue sécuritaire absolument
catastrophique donc qu'il faut et année
110 mais vous avez raison de dire que ce
n'est pas la seule réponse je rappelle
d'abord que en guadeloupe nous avons
déjà eu une crise c'était en 2009
cette crise car oui cette crise là était
une crise forte profonde des solutions
est apportée sûrement pas suffisante qui
était pas lié seulement en contexte
sécuritaire qui était liée aux services
publics dans ce territoire là
observer la manière dont deux en
guadeloupe on a limité l'accès à l'eau
durant la crise sanitaire on a
aujourd'hui une inéquité flagrante
d'accès à l'eau dans ce territoire là
les services publics d'éducation sont
dans un état catastrophique
l'hôpital est dans un état
catastrophique
et donc aujourd'hui à celle de la
méthode c'est la force
de ce sujet pour l'instant vous dites
des moyens si ce sont les mêmes sujets
sont les mêmes sujets qui ont mis le feu
aux poudres imaginez que c'est seulement
la question du pass sanitaires et la
question de la vaccination qui
obligatoire qui a mis le feu aux poudres
c'est ne rien comprendre que
j'appartiens la seule
contestation très forte et elle est
visible dans les chiffres de
nous sommes à 80 % de vacciner plus de
18 ans sur le territoire métropolitain
nous sommes à peine à 50 % notamment en
guadeloupe mais il faut bien dire que
c'est un territoire que nous avons
abandonné je le dis et je pèse mes mots
donc vous avez une responsabilité là
dessus tous les pouvoirs publics depuis
20 ans ont une responsabilité que la
droite également la goutte d'eau
effectivement qui fait déborder le vase
c'est l'obligation vaccinale pour les
soignants et puis l'obligation du du
pass sanitaires est-ce qu'il faut selon
vous en partie cd ou renoncer à se
passer ni terre cette obligation
vaccinale ou décalés l'application est
ce que vous vous rendez compte à quel
point nous en sommes arrivés là question
de la vaccination c'est une question de
protection des populations et ce
gouvernement a réussi par sa méthode de
passage en force en faire aujourd'hui un
problème et cette question-là de la
confiance qui est une question
fondamentale en matière de santé
publique elle a été totalement évacuée
par le gouvernement mais c'est le
gouvernement de lancer les élus locaux
qui qu'ils ont trop aussi le
gouvernement moi je veux bien que ce
gouvernement se déchargent totalement de
sa responsabilité
mais cette incapacité qu'il a eu à
dialoguer notamment avec les autorités
locales on peut pas négliger que
notamment la médecine traditionnelle
dans ces territoires est extrêmement
forte qu'il ya des croyances en la
médecine traditionnelle qu'on peut pas
balayer d'un revers de la main nous vu
de la métropole en disant ne comprennent
rien nous avons l'intelligence et la
science ils ont les traditions n'est pas
une urgence sanitaire au bout d'un
moment quand on l'a vu dans une urgence
mes gars là regardez le résultat
l'urgence sanitaire c'est de faire en
sorte que nous puissions vacciner le
maximum de personnes l'urgence sanitaire
c'est pas d'imposer quelque chose pour
se protéger si les gens veulent pas se
faire vacciner vous faites quoi eh bien
il faut travailler sur la confiance
pardon de vous le redire qu'est ce que
ça veut dire dialoguées comme cela
aurait dû être le cas dès l'origine vous
imaginez les conditions de dialogue
aujourd'hui ce qui va se passer c'est
qu'on va repousser la date d'obligations
de vaccination c'est ce qui va se passer
parce que nous inspire cette affirmation
oui j'appuie cette affirmation sur le
résultat nous avons réussi par le passé
qu'à cela n'est pas dû à une errance en
outre mer la résistance hal est pas
nouvelle nous avons déjà eu des grandes
campagnes de vaccination en outre mer
nous avons eu déjà des grandes campagnes
de santé publique en outre mer c'est pas
la première fois que nous le faisons et
par le passé il a fallu redoubler
d'efforts pour réussir un autre maire a
envoyé le gign répondre lorsqu'on en est
là c'est que déjà on a échoué parmi les
revendications qu'on entend actuellement
il ya la revendication d'une hausse des
salaires d'une augmentation des salaires
vous dites bon coup il faut augmenter
les salaires pour calmer un peu la crise
ce que je dis pour faire des
propositions c'est qu'à l'issue de la
réunion qui a lieu ce soir d'abord
permettez-moi une parenthèse lorsqu'il
ya eu des crises de ce niveau de gravité
des membres du gouvernement ont
jusque-là systématiquement étaient
dépêchés sur place sur place ça aussi
c'est un symbole moi j'ai souvenir de
membres du gouvernement qu'ils allaient
passer un mois dans les territoires
d'outre-mer avec tous les chefs
d'administration bastien leguay
qu'est-ce qui fait le gouvernement
encore à paris on a des scènes d'émeute
et donc jeudi et j'affirme facilement 6
à des scènes d'émeutes le gouvernement
doit être sur place évidemment lorsqu'on
aime gouvernement le gouvernement de la
france et contient la république on va
sur place on se planque pas à paris
parce que c'est alors non pas autre
chose à faire que d'accueillir
un ministre et 17 juillet toutes les
deux se trouvent il se trouve que les
autorités d'états sont déjà protégés en
guadeloupe on anime préfet on a des
représentants l'état qui sont déjà
protégés je dis simplement qu'il faut à
l'issue de cette réunion sûrement
prendre un peu plus de temps moi
j'assume de le dire je pense qu'il faut
reporter la date parce qu'on voit bien
que dans la situation actuelle nous
sommes n'y arriveront pas il faut tenir
l'impératif de vaccination parce que
c'est capital et trouver des solutions
structurelles notamment sur la question
de l'accès à l'eau c'est cela qui doit
sortir de la réunion de ce soir avec le
problème emmanuel macron a dit qu'il ne
fallait rien céder au mensonge et à la
manipulation est ce qu'il n'ya pas aussi
une instrumentalisation de la situation
et par qui selon vous mais qu'il y ait
des fakes news qu'il y une forme le
complotisme qui traînent dans le fond de
l'air depuis plusieurs semaines c'est
une évidence d'ailleurs je suis
favorable à la vaccination je lui ai
toujours poussé j'ai aucun sujet sur ce
sur ce point là mais je veux simplement
dire que on peut pas être binaire dans
cette période là on a trop été binaire
et il faut accepter de retrouver le
chemin de la confiance je mène la
confiance ça veut dire revenir vers les
français leur expliquer pourquoi la
vaccination est nécessaire comprendre
ceux qui sont hostiles à la vaccination
et ne pas les balayer d'un revers de la
main en considérant que ce sont des fous
à lier ou des complotistes non c'est
plus compliqué que ça dans le lot je
reçois des femmes et des hommes qui sont
aujourd'hui des professionnels
hospitaliers des sages femmes qui
refusent la vaccination se sont sûrement
pas les folles sont sûrement pas les
complotistes 1 mais fond et j'ai besoin
vous leur parlez vous alors c'est bien
sûr pourquoi la question agite c'était
de savoir si les élus sur place ont
assumé ce discours pro vaccinale où
est-ce qu'ils sont restés dans une
espèce de zone grise un peu ambigu ils
sont laids s'engouffrer évidemment tous
les doutes et toutes les peurs vous avez
raison ils sont restés dans l'ambiguïté
on a eu des déclarations de certains
élus locaux qui était une grande
ambiguïté pour l'heure à des jouets mais
bien sûr que je le regrette je le
dénonce même lorsqu'on est un élu de la
république en particulier lorsqu'on est
un territoire et départements
d'outre-mer on a une responsabilité
profonde et donc j'ai toujours dénoncé
ces discours là mais je dis simplement
qu'on ne peut pas considérer qu'il y ait
un camp contre neutre en matière de
santé publique il faut se souvenir que
la confiance est sûrement l'ingrédient
le plus difficile à construire mais le
plus fondamental pour la réussite on va
parler sanitaire on va continuer à
parler de sanitaires la cinquième vague
et la gabriela talent parlé hier de
fulgurances vous partagez ce diagnostic
je sais pas je ne suis pas
épidémiologistes d'ailleurs je pense que
gabriella talent ne l'est pas non plus
et si peut-être il restait dans une rue
du christ où il consultait il consulte
beaucoup il parle beaucoup peut-être que
sur ces sujets là il nous faut être
prudent d'abord je veux vous dire que
cette méthode parce que je crois que
c'est une méthode et je vais vous parler
librement puissent convenu de le faire
qui consiste à effrayer a agité la peur
est une méthode de gouvernement que je
n'accepte plus je ne dis pas qu'il n'ya
pas un problème sanitaire et nous en
avons nous avons une flambée épidémique
incontestablement est ce que c'est une
cinquième bague je n'en sais rien en
tous les cas on a une flambée épidémique
mais jeudi aux membres du gouvernement
ne vous habituer pas à gouverner avec la
peur ne vous habituer pas à rajouter des
monts à une situation qui est déjà une
situation de gravité ce que vous feriez
si vous étiez au pouvoir je pense que
d'abord j'aurais réarmer déjà depuis
plusieurs semaines les outils qui nous
permet de la vaccination vous savez
qu'on a déconstruit tout un tas de lieux
de vaccination de vaccinodromes je pense
que si on avait anticipé on aurait dû
les maintenir armée il va être très
difficile de les réarmer on va perdre
deux semaines dans leur ai remis un an
d'anticipation selon vos du gouvernement
évidemment d'ailleurs moi qui ne suis
pas épidémiologistes j'entendais déjà
les spécialistes durant cet été nous
expliquer qu'il y avait de fortes
chances qu avec la question des
températures qu'avec la reste que la
question d'une vie sociale c'est là on a
quand même fait vaccination qui est très
élevé en france c'est plutôt la question
la troisième dose qui se pose
aujourd'hui comment convaincre ceux qui
ne veulent pas les réticents les
réfractaires nous avons autour de 20 %
de nos concitoyens qui ne sont pas
vaccinés c'est un problème et je ne
pense pas qu'on puisse passer à la
question la 3e 2 en abandonnant l'idée
de convaincre encore ses concitoyens
vous rendez compte que en termes de
santé publique je parle vraiment en
termes de santé publique imaginez que
désormais dans notre pays y est presque
un quart de nos concitoyens qui
souhaitent à la marge d'une grande
opération de santé publique qu'est ce
qui va se passer quand on va relancer
les grandes campagnes de vaccination
autour de la grippe quand on m'a lancé
les grandes campagnes de prévention
autour des cancers des femmes notamment
qu'est-ce qui va
on est devant je pense que s'il s'étonne
de nos grands défis d'ailleurs les
professionnels de la santé publique le
10 c'est ce danger d'avoir rompu la
confiance et que non seulement cela
vaille pour le vaccin contre
l'épidémie dont connaissons mais aussi
pour toutes les autres campagnes n'avait
pas dit ce qu'on fait je ferais s'est
réarmé aujourd'hui nos vaccinodromes
poussé à la vaccination en troisième
dose j'ai toujours dit et je le leur dis
et à les convaincre celles et ceux qui
ne sont pas
et c'est sans doute la situation est
mauvaise et que le taux de contamination
a doublé en une semaine est ce que vous
regrettez pas finalement vous ici à
l'assemblée nationale d'avoir voté
contre la prolongation du pass
sanitaires et l'état d'urgence sanitaire
non absolument pas et je pense même que
nous avons bien fait en tous les cas moi
j'assume totalement mais est-ce que la
vaccination empêche la flambée
épidémique vous avez fait la réponse
tout à leur nom et donc à chaque fois
que
les cas graves la transmission du lit
seulement je vous dis simplement lorsque
le gouvernement on répondait quoi cette
question ça m'intéresse quand vous posez
cette question allait pas innocente est
ce que le vaccin réduit la flambée
épidémique
non j'ai pas dis réduit j'ai dit empêche
empêche mais c'est pas la même chose la
fin de réduire oui et non réduits oui
évidemment puisque c'est ce qui nous
protège c'est pour ça que je suis
vacciné que je pousse mes concitoyens
nous vacciner en revanche le discours du
gouvernement et je veux être précis qui
consistait à dire si vous votez contre
le pass and it erp vous aurez
l'explosion épidémique si vous votez
pour le pass sanitaire vous n'aurez pas
l' explosion épidémique c'est ce que
nous avons entendu à l'assemblée
nationale de la bouche du ministre vers
ans lorsque moi même je lui ai posé la
question en lui disant est ce que vous
pouvez garantir que si nous votons le
pass annie terre nous n'aurons plus de
hrw lambert efficace pour vous le passez
année je n'ai pas j'ai pas dit que la
vaccination n'était pas efficace j'ai
dit que la question du pass sanitaires
se poser c'est pour elle m'a posé un
principe fondamental qui consistait à
restreindre nos libertés ce que je ne
souhaitais pas et je peux totalement
assumée de le dire sans passer pour
irresponsable en disant bien que oui je
suis favorable à la vaccination oui
j'étais hostile opa sanitaires et
j'assume de le dire et d'ailleurs je
constate aujourd'hui que la vaccination
nous protège que le pass sanitaire n'est
pas ce qui nous a le plus compté jusque
vous êtes favorable à la troisième dose
pour tous si un quizz avec des jeux
utilitaires je lui dis il faut que les
professionnels de santé qui ne suit pas
il faut que les professionnels de santé
dont je ne suis pas nous disent à partir
de quel âge c'est acceptable de le faire
et c'est à eux de nous le dire et je
leur ferai confiance comme je lé fais
sur la première dose la deuxième manche
mais ce furent mes témoins ce qui est
important et on est témoin une remarque
je mesure qu'il est très difficile de
tenir ce discours là sans basculer dans
un camp dans notre et je pense que le la
responsabilité politique d'un
député elle est de refuser de choisir un
camp contre neutre et je ne choisirai
pas un camp contre un autre d'ailleurs
dans ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
vous avez dit quelque chose d'important
est ce que je regrette d'avoir voté
contre la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire mais pas du tout
parce que c'est un autre sujet la
prolongation jusqu'à juillet de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire c'est une question
démocratique pas une question sanitaire
et un camp qui demandent en tout cas le
retour des tests gratuits en la personne
de jean-luc mélenchon qu'est ce que vous
en pensez vous il a raison
si nous avons une flambée épidémique
s'il faut repasser à des étapes de
vaccination alors il nous faut l'autre
arme qui est l arme initial tester et
donc revenir aux tests gratuits ainsi
nous sommes dans cette circonstance il a
écouté ça fait deux ans qu'on est sur du
coin qu'il en coûte vous souvenez on
nous a répété souvent testé isolé puis
ensuite maxine et on peut pas à faire
sauter la premier le premier maillon si
on est à nouveau dans une situation
d'urgence qui celui du test est donc oui
en effet c'est une arme parmi les autres
si nous sommes à nouveau se réarmer est
en place et annette est d'un confort
tant pis il ya les thèses de confort il
y en a eu depuis deux ans je sais pas si
le test est vraiment une situation de
confort en tous les cas c'est une arme
si nous sommes à nouveau en guerre il
faut utiliser toutes les armes on a vu
que l'allemagne avait décidé un
confinement des non vaccinés est ce que
ça vous paraît possible en france c'est
inacceptable et là je mets les vrais
démocratiquement contre cette idée c'est
pas un peu d'idées dupas sanitaire
quelques pas de manière hypocrite
sûrement et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça en
cohérence que je me suis opposé mais je
voudrais attirer votre attention sur un
autre point est-ce qu'il ya trois ans
nous aurions eu ces débats là s'il ya
trois ans nous y serions dit qu'il
faudrait un pas salutaire et que
peut-être même nous évoque aurions
l'idée d' isoler une partie de la
population et pas une autre et s'il ya
trois ans nous avions eu ce débat sur ce
même plateau mouvement et a pris pour un
fou je pense qu'aujourd'hui les fous ce
ne sont pas ceux qui posent des
questions et bien que quelque chose de
dingue il est temps le virus
on a parlé d'un pensée et d'un pense
nous sommes d'accord mais il est temps
que nous retrouvions nos esprit
démocratique des
questions sur les violences contre les
femmes vas-y bouge ça steve alors les
services de police et de gendarmerie ont
enregistré une hausse de 10% des
violences conjugales cette année en
dépit du bracelet anti rapprochement qui
est une loi qu'elle vous avez contribué
ici très largement à l'assemblée
nationale est-ce que c'est toi
finalement elle est insuffisante non
elle n'est pas insuffisante on en a tiré
quelques conclusions il ya plusieurs
semaines de cela notamment dans le cadre
de la loi que j'ai portée nous
accélérions la délivrance des
ordonnances de protection qui permettent
de protéger les femmes il fallait plus
deux mois et demi jusque là pour les
obtenir dans la loi nous avons écrit
qu'il fallait six jours et je peux vous
annoncer que près de 100% des zorros de
protection sont désormais délivrés en
six jours quand on brasse et andy
rapprochement il se passe ce que j'ai
dit depuis le jour où j'ai fait voter la
loi j'ai bien dit que tant que les
magistrats ne seraient pas eux mêmes
volontaires de délivrer des bracelets
anti rapprochement on avait beau créer
l'outil ce qui était déjà une révolution
dans la loi que nous avons porté il nous
manquerait ceux qui pratiquent l'outil
et nous en sommes là aujourd'hui et
pourquoi ils traînent des pieds ils
traînent des pieds pour plusieurs
raisons une raison culturelle sûrement
une autre raison plus profonde qui le
fait que le bracelet anti rapprochement
il est intéressant avant que l'individu
ne passe à l'acte dans la phase qu'on
appelle pressentant si elle est c'est à
dire avant la sentence est aujourd'hui
c'est le juge aux affaires familiales
qui doit délivrer cette décision la juge
aux affaires familiales juge civil il ne
sait pas faire quelque chose qui
ressemble à du pénal c'est la raison
pour laquelle déjà depuis deux ans
j'appelle de mes voeux la création d'une
juridiction spécialisée pour protéger
les femmes qui associe le juge civil et
le juge pénal voilà deux ans que je le
demande voilà deux ans que je le répète
voilà près de dix ans que les espagnols
ont fait il est temps de passer des
paroles aux à la loi je suis un peu
insuffisantes aujourd'hui il faut aller
plus loin en tout cas en créant une fois
passée la juridiction spécialisée comme
nous ne l'avons fait dans notre pays en
1945 en créant le juge des enfants les
espagnols l'ont fait et c'est ce qu'il
faut faire mais vous savez sur ces
sujets lorsque nous avons porté la loi
nous avons poussé le gouvernement à
passer du baratin aux actes et je parle
bien de barre à terre parce que le bras
sans dire franchement voilà dix ans que
nous en parlions sens la loi nous avons
porté il n'aurait pas été génial lisez
sur la juridiction spécialisée il est
temps que le gouvernement arrête de
communiquer est pas ça la vraie
révolution d'organisation le droit des
femmes grande cause du quinquennat quel
bilan vous en tirez vous j'en tire un
bilan modéré sûrement parlons nous de
plus en plus de ces sujets c'est une
chose heureuse mais je voudrais vous
dire que la libération de la parole
d'une femme c'est une chose la
protection d'une femme c'est bien plus
important encore ce que je vais vous
dire par là et c'est important on ne
pousse beaucoup les femmes à parler et
c'est capital mais il faut comprendre
que c'est lorsqu'elle parle qu'elles
sont en danger de mort si une fois
qu'elles ont appuyé le 39 19 on n'est
pas capable de les protéger dans l'heure
qui suit on les met en danger de mort
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui qu'ici
on peut être un peu plus politique un
eric zemmour probable candidat à la
présidentielle est ce que son discours
vous dites que se sont dit ce qu est une
menace pour les femmes pour le droit des
femmes en général je ne me sens rien de
commun avec eric zemmour parce que
j'aime la france j'aime la ve république
on va en parler après mais je pense
qu'eric zemmour n'est sûr les familles
la dévie la république et le discours
qu'il a sur les femmes et pour moi un
discours disqualifiant
je ne comprends pas comment on peut
aimer la france et la république en
considérant que les femmes soient des
citoyennes de seconde zone ce n'est pas
l'idée que je me fais de mon pays
très vite à une question sur pouvoir
d'achat rapidement oui et ce revenu
vital que vous appelez de vos voeux qui
est un revenu pour les jeunes 715 euros
à partir de 18 ans tous les jeunes et
sous condition de servir aussi l'intérêt
général aucun candidat et l'eire n'a
repris cette proposition est ce que vous
considérez que la droite consacre
aujourd'hui trop de temps au régalien et
pas suffisamment le social on progresse
hier lors du débat les avis bertrand
rejoint par les autres candidats a
évoqué la question du handicap comme
grande cause mais voilà une vraie
progression j'ai entendu michel par
dizaines à faire j'ai entendu michel
barnier hier proposer la location
sociale unique c'est la première voie
vers la ressource que j'évoquais dans
trois ans oui
il était temps pour la droite il était
temps pour les français quelle élection
arrive à effacer mais nous avons encore
quelques mois et je suis nous avons une
grande force et que nous progressons vie
merci beaucoup
steve dans un instant il est même tout
de suite dans un instant nous allons
accueillir yves thréard qui va vous
poser des questions évidemment sur la
primaire de la droite mais tout de suite
nous prenons la direction du figaro où
nous rejoint ou plutôt nous retrouvons
vincent roux vous êtes là vincent
bonsoir merci au jour
vous occupez du figaro live qu'est ce
qui mobilise les lecteurs quelque chose
me dit que le match ol om interrompu
hier soir fait beaucoup causer entre
guillemets we are beaucoup de beaucoup
de commentaires beaucoup de réactions à
propos justement des des mesures qui est
qui ont été prises ou qui n'ont pas été
prises autour du match ol om d'abord
peut-être une première question aurélien
pradié vous quelles solutions vous
préconiserait quelle solution les
républicains préconise pour endiguer la
violence dans les stades la sanction je
suis un passionné de sport je ne
supporte pas de voir que les lieux de
vie sportive sont aujourd'hui des lieux
de violence pour moi le moindre
débordement doit conduire à l'arrêt
immédiat du match et toutes celles et
ceux qui sont concernés doivent être
interdits de match au moins pour deux
ans interdit de stade au moins pour deux
années je suis intraitable sur ces
sujets et je pense qu'il faut que nous
le soyons dans quatre jours de matches
sanction ouais
j'ai évoqué des sanctions en dix ans
toutes celles et ceux qui ont commis des
actes de violence dans des lieux
sportifs doivent être interdits de stade
au moins pour deux ans pour moi c'est
une sanction qui doit être immédiate et
systématique vous savez ces lieux là ils
sont essentiels pour les valeurs
positives qu'il devrait véhiculer mais
en plus pour la vision public qu'ils
donnent le spectacle d'hier soir qui est
vu par des millions de téléspectateurs
est un spectacle absolument terrible
j'étais tout à l'heure ce matin dans un
lycée à gourdon à cahors pas redondant
dans mon département et j'avais des
jeunes qui évoqué cela en disant mais
cette violence là pour nous elle est
devenue absolument quotidienne y compris
dans les lieux de sport qui devrait
éduquer à autre chose merci vincent à
tout à l'heure vincent roux en direct du
figaro live je vous présente est ce
utile est ce nécessaire il très abrite
auriez lycée directeur adjoint du figaro
bonsoir il avait très bon soir liens
précieux alors est ce que vous êtes
durée trois débats une primaire qui
débouchera sur un congrès qui est en
fait une primaire fermée entre
sympathisants et plutôt en train dé rend
aux républicains et on disait on disait
tous d'ailleurs les commentateurs y
compris que vous étiez pris en tenaille
entre eux eric zemmour d'un côté de
marine le pen et de l'autre
à emmanuel macron est ce que vous êtes
rassurés aujourd'hui vous ne me croirez
pas mais je n'étais pas très inquiet ah
bon tous les cas nous respirons et c'est
vrai que tous ceux qui nous avaient
progressivement t'enterrer se rend
compte que nous sommes bien vivants il y
avait des indicateurs à cela auquel nous
aurions dû vous comme moi être attentif
nous avons gagné toutes les élections
locales c'est pas négligeable y compris
celles qu'on nous annonce est de voir
perdre je pense aux élections régionales
et puis progressivement autour de
christian jacob dans la discrétion
peut-être sans faire de grands éclats
nous sommes remis au travail nous avons
rassemblé la famille politique il ya
quelques semaines encore on nous disait
que nous ne réussirions pas à mettre
tous les prétendants à la présidentielle
autour de la même table c'est chose
faite on lisait qu'ils allaient
s'écharper il ne s'échappe pas et il se
respecte on nous disait que le sujet
allait tourner en rond ça s'est un peu
c'était un peu vrai serveur car c'était
un peu vrai au début si vous voulez que
je sois tout à fait sincère s'était
beaucoup beaucoup moins le cas dès hier
où on arrive à des sujets nouveaux et ce
sera encore moins le cas la semaine
prochaine bref nous sommes en train de
vous construire qu'ils arrivent à se
distinguer parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'ils disent tous la même chose
finalement et c'est plutôt heureux
puisque nous sommes dans la même famille
politique oui non mais enfin bon pour
l'enfant organiser une primaire je
comprends que ce soit fâcheux pour ceux
qui assistent au spectacle mais pour
nous c'est plutôt rassurant je préfère
que chacun de nos candidats garde ses
forces pour aller ensuite face à
emmanuel macron qui est notre adversaire
politique et puis surtout c'est sûr ça
ça sera lui l'adversaire en tous les cas
c'est lui le président de la république
sortant et nous nous aspirons à être les
futurs responsables politiques du pays
et donc notre concurrence et emmanuel
macron en effet et d'ailleurs je pense
que parmi toutes les grandes familles
politiques dans le pays aujourd'hui les
français sont en train de se rendre
compte que les républicains sont les
plus sérieux les plus crédibles est-ce
que vous n'êtes pas d'accord pour dire
quand même que la présence de madame le
pen et monsieur zemmour
qui occupe beaucoup de terrain
d'ailleurs sur le plan des dans les
sondages dans les dents les opinions
exprimées par les français aujourd'hui
dans les sondages ça vous oblige et ça
oblige les cinq candidats qui
participent à cette primaire justement
une espèce de course à l'échalote sur
les sujets dits régaliens c'est un des
dangers potentiels vous êtes un comme ça
oui c'est un danger je crois que les
candidats il résiste plutôt pas mal les
questions de sécurité les questions
d'émigration sur des questions
essentielles pour nos concitoyens et je
disais au début de l'émission vous étiez
cerveau gauche c'est déjà une bonne
nouvelle que je sois qu' une partie du
mot qu'ils soient cerveau
sans le cerveau vous devriez pas inquiet
on ne sent pas du tout de gauche
d'ailleurs j'ai toujours dit à mes amis
à mes camarades que la grande
responsabilité de la droite républicaine
c'était de porter un espoir pas une
punition
en 1995 voit pas l'espoir là quand même
ici ce qui c'est c'est tout le travail
que nous devons mener en 1995 c'est que
healy oui voilà mais je reconnais que et
c'est ce que je plaide le désir quoi que
ce soit je plaide depuis quatre ans
portait un espoir pas une punition en
1995 jacques chirac a un discours très
dur sur le régalien
rappelé le bruit l'odeur et ses quelques
années avant ils gagnent sur la fracture
sociale sur un espoir de cohésion
sociale en 2007 nicolas sarkozy a un
discours très dur sur le régalien plus
karcher vous en souvenez il gagne sur le
travailler plus pour gagner plus bref la
droite française d'ailleurs comme toutes
les familles politiques ne peuvent
emporter l'élection présidentielle que
si les incarne un espoir et cet espoir à
mon sens il est autour de la cohésion
sociale la cohésion sociale ça veut pas
dire quoi la cohésion sociale la
cohésion sociale ses commandes mais nous
sommes capable de refonder totalement
l'idée qu'on se fait du salaire je pense
que nous avons dans ce pays un vrai
sujet avec les salaires pas seulement
l'augmentation est pas l'augmentation
mécanique par le smic et comment
faisons-nous en sorte demain que chaque
salarié de ce pays puisse bénéficier
d'une vraie participation l'entreprise
gagne de l'argent après vous êtes un
gaulliste de gauche c'est ça je suis un
gaulliste points derrière le mot
gaullisme ont nommé ni droite ni gauche
on met la france et ça suffit et donc je
considère que cette question des
salaires est l'essentiel quand on y est
nos candidats vont sur le terrain du
handicap qui n'est pas un sujet de niche
qui est un sujet de transformation
profonde de la société qui est un sujet
d'espoir pour plusieurs millions de nos
concitoyens alors je pense qu'ils vont
sur le chemin de ce chemin d'espérance
pour la droite française être ferme sur
l'autorité et être juste sur les
questions sociales l'ascenseur social
voilà un sujet qui est un sujet le
mérite républicain que qui ressemble à
la droite il est totalement en panne
vous rendez compte que vous êtes vous
êtes vous êtes en train de nous dire que
la droite doit renouer avec le peuple
elle doit renouer avec l'idée que l'on
ne faisons de la république
je disais à mes camarades candidats lors
du conseil national samedi que nous
avons aujourd'hui un enfant fils
d'ouvrier cinq ans après être rentré sur
le marché du travail va gagner 1000
euros de moins qu'un enfant fils de
bourgeois et bien ça c'est un sujet sur
lequel la droite française doit lutter
pas la lutte des classes mais le mérite
républicain et cet espoir là je pense
que nous avons matière à le porter et ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle aussi
l'émancipation individuelle c'est pas
non plus une idée qui est porté par
emmanuel macron me semble que si non
parce qu emmanuel macron à une vision
injuste de la société il considère que
ceux qui ont des accidents de la vie ne
mérite pas d'être accompagné et je pense
d'ailleurs que c'est un des sujets de
vos caricatures non non qu'elle me suis
dur je prononce ses phrases ceux qui ont
réussi et ceux qui ne sont rien une
phrase du président de la république
d'une violence inouïe personne n'est
rien dans ce pays les premiers de cordée
les dernier de cordée traverse la rue
pour trouver du boulot tout ça ce sont
des discours d'enfants gâtés et nous
devons nous la droite républicaine être
capables de nous adresser autant à ceux
pour qui la vie est facile qu'à ceux
pour qui la vie est difficile en leur
disant si tu travailles tu pourra
réussir c'est ça la promesse république
alors il ya eu trois débats vous
connaissez bien les impétrants il ya eu
en plus leurs discours devant le conseil
national où vous étiez
quel est votre préféré
je n'ai pas de préférence
parce que
si bilité parce que vous nous avez là
vous nous avez défini votre droite c'est
une droite sociale s'il droite qui est
sensible aux questions droit de gaulle
salaires droite gaulliste bah oui le
gommer oui mais depuis de gaulle
justement là la droite a pas mal perdu
alors c'est qui le bon on vous pose la
question des ferments ça ne peut pas
être ou qui voit là par élimination
censé livrer davantage je vais être je
vais être honnête avec vous
j'apprécie chez michel barnier
l'habitude
et la sérénité j'apprécie chez xavier le
sens de l'ascenseur social j'apprécie
chez valérie pécresse ce volontarisme
républicain et chez eric ciotti
l'exigence républicaine comme chez
philippe duval le sens des
bertrand si je vous réponds clairement
je pense que un peu de tout se fera un
très bon candidat et ça tombe bien
puisque nous aurons une équipe de france
a constitué oui mais ça c'est du lourd
c'est des éléments de langage
elisabeth a raison il y en a un qui
correspond peut-être davantage
d'eux mêmes qu'ils correspondent
peut-être davantage chez eric ciotti qui
est assez offensif sur ces questions
justement de pouvoir d'achat de baisse
des impôts pour
essayer de donner plus aux français et
puis effectivement xavier bertrand qui
lui est dans la fibre gaulliste social
pour tout vous dire est très honnête je
n'ai pas encore pris ma décision mais je
la prends la connaîtra publiquement je
ne pense pas que vous la connaissiez
avant le vote des adhérents pour une
raison simple c'est que christian jacob
et moi avons fait ce choix en organisant
le système de vote de ne pas prendre
part ce qui est compréhensible c'est pas
une volonté de ma part de me planquer je
plaque rappelant que rarement ce n'est
pas vraiment ma réputation mais on ne
peut pas organiser le mode électoral et
influencer les adhérents mais je me
déciderai sur un point qui est de me
souvenir que nous allons désigner le
candidat à la présidentielle un futur
chef d'état pas un chef de clan il
s'agit pas de choisir le futur président
des républicains nous avons déjà un très
bon présent dans les plis cas c'est
christian jacob et donc je le dis aux
adhérents comme je dis partout dans les
fédérations je vais la veille du premier
tour je me déciderai en me demandant qui
a le plus de chance d'en remporter la
victoire devant les français d'accord
alors dernière question il ya emmanuel
macron qui fait la course en tête dans
les études d'opinion actuellement après
il est suivi par madame le pen monsieur
émaux et vous arrivez le plus souvent en
4ème position quand même lequel est
d'après vous le plus redoutable entre
eric zemmour et marine le pen je ne sais
pas moi je me sens rien de commun avec
eric zemmour je le dis très sereinement
rien mais je pèse mes mots d'abord je
trouve qu'on lui donne beaucoup de
superbes le mot nationalisme vous fait
pousser des boutons non mais mais mais
le mot pétain oui le mot cerveau
archaïque pour les femmes oui lorsque je
vois un homme se comporter comme comme
un gamin entre là en ayant entre les
mains une mitraillette et en visant des
journalistes oui ça me donne des boutons
et ce qui m'intrigue beaucoup c'est la
superbe qu'on donne à eric zemmour on le
trouve superbement bon écrivain jeux
cultes quelque chose comme je le pense
je trouve qu'il écrit avec les pieds je
n'aime pas le lire on le trouve
superbement historiens c'est un très
mauvais historiens qui cite toujours les
mêmes références et souvent de mauvaise
référence qui commet des fautes graves
notamment en reprenant l'argumentaire de
l'avocat de pétain pour justifier cette
page sombre de l'histoire je le trouve
mauvais politique je trouve qu'il commet
des fautes majeures et surtout je lui
trouve une fois de considérables c'est
je pense qu'ils n'aiment pas la france
ouais je pense que pour lui la france
est l'exutoire de toutes ces tortures
personnel et moi l'idée que je me fais
de la france c'est l'idée d'une
magnifique promesses qui s'adresse
autant aux petits gamins qui s'appelle
mohamed à clichy-sous-bois coup petit
gamin qui s'appelle aurélien dans le lot
pourvu qu'ils respectent les valeurs de
la république tout ça c'était un verre
ça ce qu'eric zemmour et le réquisitoire
est ce que vous faites le même contre
madame marine le pen oui je les fais
depuis le début et je continuerai à le
faire on ne peut pas aimer la france et
vouloir présider la france si on ne veut
pas la rassembler et je pense que la
droite républicaine est la seule à
pouvoir rétablir l'ordre républicain et
rassembler les français merci beaucoup
ils frère donc on n'aura pas le choix 1
mais on vous le connaîtrez le sait si
l'on peut faire des paris merci à vous
avec ce que vous avez dit à l'instant
sur eric zemmour s'il était en duel avec
emmanuel macron en aucun cas jamais vous
ne pourriez voter pour lui je me sens
avec la même circonstance je consacrerai
toutes mes forces pour que ça n'arrive
pas et si ça devait arriver mais je ne
sais pas de supputations non mais vous
ai dit mon malheur vous supportiez
qu'emmanuel mal france serait votre
adversaire je vais donc je veux pas
faire des supputations dans un sens dans
un nom ait été assez clair il avait
demandé joue pour vous dire que je
n'avais rien de commun avec eric zemmour
et que pourquoi ne pas me dire oui ou
non parce que mon boulot mon boulot de
responsables politiques c'est de tout
faire pour que ça n'arrive pas et cette
question est les tomes piège pour la
droite républicaine c'est ni l'un ni
l'autre parce que tu as besoin un
éclaircissement l étonnante les agences
de l'éclaircissement c'est ce que j'ai
dit sur eric zemmour je le dirai et je
le répèterai toujours la même manière y
compris sur marine le pen mais je
conseille vous voulez mais fort
d'une seule phrase la possibilité qu'ils
puissent être au deuxième tome donc
parce que ça n'arrivera pas et que j'y
consacrerai toutes mes forces voilà
chacun en tirera les conclusions qu'il
le souhaite je vous présente en face de
vous merci beaucoup mais dames mélanie
vogel sénatrice europe ecologie les
verts une souris français de l'étranger
c'est l'arrêt de cette émission de
parlementaires viennent vous interpeller
sur des sujets qui leur tiennent à coeur
elles ont chacune une carte blanche on
verra ça tout à l'heure mais aussi on va
les retrouver sur un thème commun et
c'est vous qui allez commencer par
christine verdier joucla bonsoir vous
êtes député la république en marge du
tarn porte parole du groupe la
république en marche à l'assemblée et
donc le thème commun ça va vous parler
c'est le territoire le lien au
territoire et c'est marie-christine
verde jouclas qui emmanuel macron et
depuis le début du quinquennat ou
presque accusés de ne pas avoir
entretenu peut-être même d'avoir méprisé
à un moment ce lien avec les territoires
c'est à vous
on l'a même en lui même expliqué que
dans la mesure où il n'était pas un élu
il pouvait pas comprendre les élus et
c'est quelque chose qu'on m'a reproché
aussi à moi puisque jamais fait de
politique j'étais pas venu locale je
crois qu'à la conclusion du congrès des
maires il a bien répondu en rappelant
que de gaulle n'était pas non plus élu
et pour autant il a su convaincre les
français de suivre donc au début c'est
ce qu'on nous reprochait de ne pas
savoir faire la politique exact mais
d'être hors sol et hors sol ça veut dire
ne pas comprendre le territoire parce
qu'on n'avait pas mandat de conseiller
municipal de mer ou autres pour autant
moi je suis arrivé forte de mon
expérience professionnelle 30 ans dans
une boîte qui m'a permis de rencontrer
pas mal de gens et puis forte aussi de
mon expérience de vie associative où
j'ai pu exercer bénévolement des
missions qui m'ont permis aussi de
rencontrer des gens et de savoir ce que
c'était en fait la vie et le terrain et
je crois que c'était le pari des manuels
macron et qu'il a réussi parce que
quatre ans et demi presque cinq ans
après je pense que je suis connue et
reconnue partout sur mon territoire et
pourtant je ne suis toujours pas mère ni
conseiller municipal que je comprends
les élus parce que à leur rencontre que
je comprends les citoyens parce que je
vais à leur rencontre les associations
les institutions et c'est donc
aujourd'hui après quatre ans et demi de
mandat monsieur pradier est ce que vous
pouvez convenir qu'il ne s'agit pas
forcément d'être un élu local pour faire
bien la mission d'un élu national non je
ne conviendrait pas été très étonné
merci pour votre question incroyable
modeste je joue toujours toujours pas
surpris avec avec vous d'abord une
remarque est que emmanuel macron aux se
comparer au général de gaulle mme paré
d'une immodestie incroyable d'une morgue
incroyable c'est une petite différence
entre emmanuel macron le général de
gaulle c'est que le général de gaulle a
embarqué les français parce qu'ils les
avaient embarqué à l'ombre qu'il avait
résisté comme aucun autre n'a résisté et
irait au delà dit l'était pas non plus
c'est ce qu'il a dit injuste le
libérateur de la france qui fait une
légère différence avec emmanuel macron
quand on est devant les maires il faut
savoir faire preuve d'humilité parce que
les mères sont au quotidien ce qui
compense que l'état n'a pas su faire
notamment durant la crise sanitaire mais
je veux répondre à votre question vous
évoquez le fait au fond résumé dans
cette phrase d'emmanuel macron soyez
fiers d'être des amateurs moi je n'ai
jamais cru en cette phrase là les
français jugeront de la qualité du
travail parlementaire depuis quatre ans
je pense qu'ils en juge assez durement
d'ailleurs
que vos collègues et on a déjà vu
puisque à chaque fois que mon collègue
le député ont été candidats aux
élections locales ils ont pris des
vestes absolument phénoménale et ça veut
dire quelque chose moi je n'ai pas
travaillé dans l'entreprise avant d'être
élu local je viens d'un milieu très
modeste très c'est mes parents faisait
pas de politique j'ai mon bac et puis
c'est tout je suis pas né avec une
cuillère en argent dans la bouche
j'ai tout appris dans mes mandats locaux
comme maire cette école s'appelle
l'école de la république et cette école
de la république elle n'est pas
négligeable ou méprise amis n'y a pas
c'est vrai ça et c'est vrai c'est la rda
république c'est vrai que lorsque
j'étais maire j'ai beaucoup appris de ce
que sont les territoires de ce qu'est la
loi de ce que sont les idéaux politiques
cette idée de s'engager pas seulement
pour remplir des tableaux excel mais
pour changer la vie de nos concitoyens
mais quand on dit l'association la
notion d'engagement je suis désolé
l'élément six thèmes aussi importants
évidemment mais je pense à me se résume
pas à ce point là cette capacité à faire
vous a beaucoup manqué depuis quatre ans
mélanie vogel sur ce sujet là cette
accusation là qu'on ne peut pas être un
bon et les locales et avoir le lien à
quel territoire si on n'est pas passé
par un certain mandat
en réalité je suis d'accord avec aucun
des deux parce que je crois pas que ce
qu'ils soient reprocher emmanuel macron
enfin en tout cas de mon point de vue je
reprocherais jamais à quelqu'un de
concourir à un mandat sans en avoir eu
un avant c'est pas du tout la vision la
démocratie que défendent les écologistes
moi même j'ai été élu récemment j'étais
pas élu avant si pour être élu il faut
avoir été élu on a quand même un
problème démocratique on envoie un
signal très négatif envers tout un tas
de personnes qui pour le droit comme
chacun et chacune de concourir à des
mandales on a tous commencé comme ça mon
arbre a élu avant d'être élu les oui
bien sûr mais l'idée que pour être élu
national il faudra
avant je pense que c'est pas quelque
chose qui est qui est correct on peut
avoir envie de s'engager plus tôt niveau
local plutôt au niveau national pour moi
c'est pas ça le problème qui est
reproché un manuel macro de mon point de
vue c'est la pratique du pouvoir très
verticale qui se fait sans
consultation des citoyens et des
citoyennes et je pense que c'est un
reproche qui peut aussi être répercutée
au niveau local donc pour moi c'est ça
la question c'est pas tellement ce qu'on
a fait avant c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait
quand on est élu et la manière de son
exerce le pouvoir mais on est sur le
sujet du lien entre les territoires vous
êtes élu des français de l'étranger
comme j'ai dit c'est pas et c'est assez
particulier combien
je livre excellent et responsable de la
delà de la réalité de l'existence de ce
mandat c'est vrai que on se demande
souvent déjà parent qui j'ai été élu
alors le petit moment pédagogique de la
soirée les sénateurs et sénatrices des
français de l'étranger sont élus par des
conseillers consulaires qui sont au même
élu par les français qui habitent à
l'étranger pour les représenter
ce qui est vrai c'est que par définition
quand on est une circonscription aussi
grande que le monde entier parce que
contrairement aux députés les sénateurs
n'ont pas de zones géographiques
c'est le monde entier à part la france
j'avoue que c'est un peu compliqué de
couvrir le territoire comme on peut le
faire contre la conscription en france
mais ce qu'il ya c'est que les français
et françaises qui habitent à l'étranger
sont confrontés à des sujets communs ils
subissent souvent disons le en fin de
course les décisions gouvernementales
quand on baisse les budgets vous savez
parfois quand on baisse les budgets dans
l'action consulaire des fois c'est une
personne un consulat quidam c'est des
milliers de personnes qui sont plus du
tout accès à aucun service mais cette
question cet enjeu physique que vous
écrivez un don à l'électeur est un vrai
enjeu différent il est différent et est
ce que on pourrait dire ben finalement
c'est une façon un peu verticale
d'exercer pouvoir non ça n'a strictement
rien à voir justement verticale je
dirais pas parce que non c'est
simplement qu'effectivement je peux pas
me déplacer dans tous les endroits du
monde c'est matériellement impossible
heureusement avec les moyens aujourd'hui
numérique on arrive à se rencontrer avec
les personnes que je représente c'est
vrai que ça s'est engagé différemment
que sur un territoire aussi pu éclaircir
ce que j'ai dit je n'ai pas dit personne
d'ailleurs ne la pensée j'imagine qu'on
était mauvaise et lui si on n'avait
jamais été vu auparavant en revanche bon
je me souviens lorsque je suis arrivé à
l'assemblée nationale les tombereaux de
leçons qu'on a reçues de ce qui n'avait
jamais été élu auparavant qui expliquait
que ceux qui avaient une expérience de
maire était forcément ou des truands ont
très influencé par jamais on a dix ans
souviens d'une expression nice a bien
accueilli ce pradier est-ce que vous
avez une mémoire défaillante mais pas
très bien je vous rassure il a raflé
vous arranger ce qui c'est à dire ça il
se trouve que vous avez prononcé la
phrase suivante le problème des députés
qui ont été élues avancé qu'il songe
sites soumis au lobby des électeurs au
lobby des citoyens vers une phrase pts
une phrase qui a été prononcée et c'est
là qu'il ya c'est là qu'il ya un vrai
problème les citoyens s'étaient pas aux
lobbys et citoyens sont ceux à qui on
doit rendre des comptes et lorsque
rendre à la personne
je pense que c'était au moment j'en suis
même assez peu près certain au moment où
nous avons examiné le texte qui a
supprimé notamment la réserve
parlementaire et c'était le ministre de
l'époque qui est qui avait prononcé
cette phrase et je peux la série fier ce
que je veux simplement dire et c'est la
question c'est qu'on ne peut pas
organiser la démocratie si nous mêmes
les députés on ne rend pas des comptes à
nos concitoyens et pas seulement à nos
concitoyens aussi à tous les corps
intermédiaires qui ont été méprisant
mais qui ont produit les sénégal après
d'être un élu local pour rendre des
comptes aux citoyens moi je lis
régulièrement un dur que cela pas mal je
fais des marchés je fais des réformes
idée je rencontre un citoyen et prison
mais je suis ça fait dix ans fait donc
voyez vous m'auriez demandé avant je
vous leur expliquez nam et c'est pour ça
et après par contre là où joue au delà
ce qu'on a dit c'est que halte à la
baronnie la baronnie c'est quand on est
maire et député depuis x années ce qu'a
voulu moi je n'ai heureusement parce
qu'il ya plus le cumul effectivement
même scène combien on en voit bien qu'à
de niche qui va revenir et qui
voudraient remettre la possibilité que
si on est maire
choisir il faut faire quand on est maire
aujourd'hui alors si vous voulez bien
vous carte blanche mesdames les
parlementaires
cette fois c'est vous qui commençait
mélanie vogel pour l'interpellation
aurélien pradié vous voulez parler de du
mythe ou politique
ma le mythe le mélies tout mais je vais
je suis sûr qu'il va pas de prix je lui
fais tout à fait conscience d'avoir
compris oui donc j'ai une question très
simple j'imagine que vous avez vu passer
le texte publié que j'espère par environ
300 femmes engagements politiques des
parlementaires des journalistes des
collaboratrices qui demande aux partis
politiques en vue des élections de
l'année prochaine pour la présidentielle
pour les législatives ainsi que pour
tout ce qui concerne l' embauche des
collaborateurs qui nous entoure
de prendre soin de ne pas parrainer
désigné ou embaucher des agresseurs
c'est une façon de changer la culture
de violences sexistes et sexuelles dans
laquelle nous évoluons et qui à terme je
pense à vocation à faire diminuer les
violences parce que en diminuant
l'impunité ont fait diminuer les
comportements violents donc ma question
est très simple est ce que les
républicains vont s'engager
sur ces trois demandes c'est un sujet
qui me tient à coeur vous le savez je
suis aussi secrétaire général les
républicains je vous ai trouvé que
c'était une bonne personne à qui poser
et je suis heureux de vous y de d'y
répondre je vais vous dire les choses
très clairement depuis que je suis
secrétaire général des républicains j'ai
eu à connaître trois situations dans
lesquelles
des hommes en l'occurrence avait commis
des actes inacceptables pas tous
condamnés encore mais certains condamnés
à chaque fois quelles que soient les
âges des concernés j'ai tout fait pour
qu'il soit écarté ces îles ont été
concernant les parties s'étaient des
membres du parti ils ont été écartés de
leurs responsabilités jusqu'à ce que
notamment les décisions de justice ne
tombe
ça n'a pas été simple
et je dois vous dire que j'y veille
autant que je le peux et que jamais
personne ne m'a empêché de le faire je
continuerai à le faire je ne sais pas si
j'y arriverais à chaque fois mais en
tous les cas ce sera ma contribution
mais donc mais parce que la question
vous été adressées en tant que
responsable pas vous individuellement
est ce que votre parti va s'engager sur
ces trois demandes oui mais nous le
faisons déjà alors il ya une chose à
laquelle je ne crois pas sont les
systèmes dans des lieux de pouvoir
c'est la politique c'est l'entreprise
sont les médias les systèmes d' alerte
ne marche pas pouvait organiser tous les
systèmes où il ya même des partis
politiques aujourd'hui qui font appel à
des entreprises et cabinets de conseils
extérieurs pour libérer la parole ça ne
marche pas ça ne marche pas parce que je
vais vous dire les choses on est au
courant des situations la réalité c'est
ça c'est personne n'ignore les
situations problématiques et c'est que
lorsqu'on est au courant que nous mêmes
dans notre bureau on doit prendre nos
responsabilités c'est ce que j'ai essayé
de faire depuis plusieurs années et
c'est ce que je continuerai à faire je
prends simplement cet engagement là
parce que ce que nous voulons vous comme
moi c'est que ça aboutisse c'est qu'à
chaque fois que vous dans votre famille
politique et je sais que vous avez eu à
connaître ces difficultés votre famille
politique comme dans la mienne dans la
responsabilité qui est la mienne comme
secrétaire général des républicains à
chaque fois je pèserai de tout mon poids
et jusque là ça a fonctionné et donc
vous écartez les personnes concernées
qui ont donné lui des plaintes privé ou
judiciaires j'imagine vous les écarter
complètement vous les exclus et du parti
dans l'unique de la présomption
d'innocence et c'est tout le défi dans
les trois cas que j'évoque dans une de
ces situations aucune décision de
justice n'avait été rendue et donc on
lui a demandé de se mettre à l'écart
parce que moi je ne suis pas juge et je
pense que oui mais ils vous ni moi
n'avons intérêt à écraser la présomption
d'innocence je sais que la décision de
justice va intervenir dans quelques
semaines s'il est blanchi il reprendra
toutes ses responsabilités et si c'est
pas le cas il n'aura pas à reprendre nos
responsabilités et par ailleurs ne pas
être désignés pour des élections
législatives ce n'est pas une décision
de justice est une décision politique
c'est des choix politique de désigner
tel ou tel personne c'est pas un
tribunal qui fait ça c'est important de
savoir exactement quelles sont les
règles auxquelles vous bénisse ces
procédures si elles sont adoptées par le
parti et c'est vrai que ce qui est très
difficile c'est de comprendre que les
systèmes ça déresponsabilise aussi les
responsables politiques moi c'est pas
simple quand j'ai eu à connaître c'est
une situation vous n'avez pas de système
que quelles sont les banques locales
sont les chemins ça a fonctionné alors 1
et christine d'abord vous avez peut-être
une petite remarque à faire et puis vous
avez votre carte blanche on vous y allez
directement il reste 4 5 minutes oui
donc je vais lui directement sur la
carte blanche
la question
c'est normal voilà donc moi je veux
revenir sur la crise donc il ya eu la
crise de l'aco vide nous avons mis en
place toutes les mesures pour tenir le
tissu économique ce sont les
fonctionnalités le pge l'exonération de
charges et surtout le chômage partiel
pour maintenir les salaires aujourd'hui
on est en sortie de crise du moins de la
situation économique avec un taux de
croissance qui est à plus de 6% avec un
taux de chômage et qui revenue à 8,1 et
qu'on n'avait pas vu depuis dix ans on a
une dette qu'on va pouvoir maintenir dès
2022 inférieur à 5% on a trois millions
de jeunes qui ont trouvé un emploi bref
on est sur la bonne pente plutôt la
bonne ascension pour retrouver une santé
économique qui va nous permettre de
continuer notre action va donc la
question que je vais vous poser c'est
est-ce que vous croyez toujours puisque
c'est ce que vous avez affirmé tout au
long de la crise avec votre party les
républicains que notre pays est en
faillite bon je veux à nouveau saluer le
milieu de votre votre question
c'est pas être ne pas être simple que de
dire les choses telles qu'elles sont de
surprenants quand même incroyable
arbitres en marche je trouve absolument
formidable tout ce que fait manuel mata
baisse les chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes
excusez moi nous allons parler des
chiffres
prenons deux chiffres d'abord le déficit
commercial nous parle beaucoup de
compétitivité de notre pays est ce que
vous savez à combien nous sommes
aujourd'hui répondait passe ici parce
que vous allez chiffres et vous dites
est ce que tout est formidable je vous
réponds prenons les chiffres le déficit
commercial nous sommes aujourd'hui à 95
milliards de déficit commercial vous
savez sûrement à quel niveau et
l'allemagne non je sais 118 milliards
d'excédent commercial oui mais est-ce
qu'on peut et est ce qu'on peut
considérer que ça va mieux vous me
parliez de la situation la dette et pisé
moi j'y viens j'y viens précisé la dette
est léger vient l'exigeait depuis très
longtemps tergiversé 6 aimant sur la
question de la dette nous avons
aujourd'hui une explosion je pèse bien
mes mots une explosion de la dette
ordinaire et à vous nous expliquer au
fond on a explosé la dette parce qu'il
ya eu la situation qu vide la cour des
comptes a été extrêmement clair sur ce
sujet
les revenus et la qualité du doigt le
fait qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes à une
augmentation de 150 milliards d'euros
sur cinq ans des dépenses ordinaires ces
repas des dépenses liées à la crise qu
vite la réalité madame verdi joucla
c'est que vous auriez pu réussir si vous
aviez mener les réformes nécessaires
n'avaient ni mener la réforme des
retraites a amené la réforme des re
visionner la réforme de l'assurance
maladie et que sur tous ces sujets vous
planquer aujourd'hui politiquement
derrière la crise qu vide alors que vous
avez abîmé y compris l'état mais je suis
votre vous êtes quand même jamais je
trouve quand même que le second fait de
parler je la dette de l'augmentation de
la dette quand dans le projet de loi de
finances que nous venons d'examiner en
quatre amendements vous allez proposer 2
milliards de dépenses supplémentaires
très bien et elle est républicaine vous
êtes attention à la dette mais vous êtes
les premiers à proposer des dépenses ce
tarif actuel est magnifique honneur
d'être en responsabilité et que vous
parlez de dépenses mises à la sauvette
dans le projet de loi de finances nous
sommes arrivés ensemble parler d'un seul
camp et était à proposer mais finalement
je vais y mettre des chefs
nous avons aussi fait trente cinq
amendements sur des réductions de
dépenses mais ça vous oublier de le dire
et sur la question de votre
responsabilité on arrive en septembre
avec un projet de finance dans lequel il
y a cinq milliards supplémentaires qui
ont été annoncées par le fait du prince
durant l'été emmanuel macron on atterrit
à la fin de l'examen budgétaire avec 15
milliards montant est bien 15 milliards
de dépenses que emmanuel macron a fait
avec le chéquier la france depuis
plusieurs semaines qu'ils ne sont même
pas ciblé dans le budget de la nation le
haut-commissariat aux finances publiques
pour la première fois vous dit que ce
budget insincère non mais attendez le
problème si vous voulez c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a pris un engagement
emblème c'est que vous avez un port
salut
mais la dette s'ils voulaient le quoi
qu'il en coûte moi je rencontre pas un
seul citoyen qui me disent pas merci de
ce qu'on a fait pour faire le quoi qu'il
en coûte alors le quoiqu'il en ce que
vous devez coup et certaines aides que
nous avons sué sur la lorien à voir avec
le coude il en coûte comme quoi mais au
lieu de la payer jusqu'à en 2000 je
crois alors autrement elle a prolongé
jeudi 21 mai spectateurs comprennent
mais nous avons dû finir nous avons voté
la de toutes les recettes
supplémentaires que nous pourrions avoir
grâce à l'argumentation de la croissance
n'irait d'abord moralement de la belette
la réalité c'est que nous sommes
aujourd'hui à 150 milliards d'explosion
de dette ne dépensent plus notre propos
ne sont pas neutres ne sont pas liées
madame verdier joucla à la crise qu vide
c'est ça la réalité on a l'impression
que vous avez vécu que la crise qu vide
vous n'avez rien fait avant nous a
persévéré dans normes parce que c'est
nécessaire elles font rien après parce
que je l'espère nous remplacerons au
pouvoir mais moi j'espère pas et oui ça
vous fait un point commun voilà merci
beaucoup
d'avoir été là tout les deux sénatrices
et députés pour interpeller aurélien
pradié ont fait un dernier détour si
vous voulez bien par le fuyard ou light
avec vincent roux vincent vous êtes avec
nous
vincent l'a aussi beaucoup de réactions
aux filières en live sur la phrase de
jean christophe lagarde dont on doit
dire avoir l'honnêteté de dire
d'ailleurs qu'il l'a finalement enfin il
s'est excusé vous vous rappelez vous
posez votre question à aurélien pradié
fait effectivement donc beaucoup de
commentaires donc autour de ses propos
de jean-christophe lagarde sur france
info hier matin je cite de la balle dans
la tête que charles pasqua ce qu'il
était vivant aurait mis ou dorées du
maître à eric zemmour hier soir xavier
bertrand valérie pécresse michel barnier
philippe juvin se sont satisfaits des
excuses et des regrets et de jean
christophe lagarde al'inverse eric
ciotti lui réclame des poursuites du
parquet
quel est votre camp rien près des monts
quand c'est celui de la démocratie du
respect de la république ça nous arrive
tous de dire des bêtises pour pas dire
autre chose jean christophe lagarde a
dit une grosse bêtise d'abord parce que
charles pasqua de mettet de balle dans
la tête de personne ce qui est important
de rappeler qu ensuite la démocratie
c'est pas ça je vous ai dit tout ce que
je pensais en mal d'eric zemmour je le
combattrai de toutes mes forces
politiquement mais jamais par la
violence et donc s'il doit être
poursuivie qu'il le soit il faudra aussi
poursuivre eric zemmour lorsqu'ils
tiennent une arme à feu et qu'il cible
les journalistes en faisant à mon sens
autant d'éloges que la violence de la
violence ce qui est grave dans notre
période c'est que la violence est
devenue ban séparés c'est pareil que les
propos de jean christophe lagarde la
bêtise de l'heure est à peu près
proportionnelle à la bêtise de l'autre
on sait par ayew pas je vous ai dit que
c'était du même acabit
ces combats jeudi violence
in arms je concilie le considère que
lorsqu'on est un responsable lourd
attendez on fait pas d'humour lorsqu'on
était un responsable politique on a une
arme à feu entre les mains surtout quand
on vous recommande autour de vous de ne
pas la prendre dans les mains et de ne
cibler personne parce que sont des
règles de sécurité fondamentales je dois
vous rappeler qu' il ya quelques
semaines
quelqu'un est mort sur un tournage parce
qu'il maniait une arme à feu alors que
toutes les conditions de sécurité
étaient réunis donc c'est irresponsable
la phrase de jean christophe lagarde on
à la pétillance concernant la préfecture
hier faisait mais autant à malaise
à la direction des républicains
vis-à-vis de ces propos de
jean-christophe lagarde on vise à
minorer mais
vous m'avez vous m'avez mal compris je
vais peut-être vous dire les jours et
pas prononcé de gros mots quand je vous
dis que ce que jean christophe lagarde a
dit une bêtise c'est pour pas dire non
plus lourd que ça je dis que c'est
irresponsable de prononcer une phrase
pareille je peux pas être plus clair
mais jeudi de la même manière que c'est
irresponsable de pointe et qui que ce
soit avec une arme à feu c'est du même
acabit et tout cela me révolte au plus
haut point parce que c'est pas l'idée
que je me fais de la démocratie merci
beaucoup vincent roux d'avoir été avec
nos une dernière question avant qu'on se
quitte en ce qui concerne la chasse
parce que parliez des hommes est ce que
vous êtes pour une limitation plus ou
moins importante des des jours de chasse
ont par demi-journée dans l'avenir ça
existe déjà dans certains territoires
je suis issu d'un territoire où on
chasse beaucoup où la cohabitation se
fait elle n'est pas toujours facile on a
eu des drames d'ailleurs et je fais
partie de ceux qui pousse au dialogue
entre les chasseurs et ceux qui
profitent de l'environnement
je ne sais pas en tout les cas il faudra
arriver à un consensus parce qu'on ne
peut pas dresser les uns contre les
autres je veux faire une parenthèse je
ne cautionne absolument pas les discours
qui ont pu être tenus par certains
responsables
de deux des chasseurs expliquant qu'ils
auraient demain un rôle de police a joué
moi tous les chasseurs que je côtoie
sont suffisamment responsables pour
respecter des règles s'il faut qu'ils
n'en respecte d'autres je pense qu'ils
sont prêtes à le faire et qu'il faut que
dans notre pays on puisse conserver la
vie des traditions et la sécurité de
tous donc vous dites un c'est une
question qu'elle est utile de mettre sur
la table de jeu n'est pas encore de
conviction totalement forgé ou un
certain jeune homme demain des sticks
oui mais c'est la réalité là parce que
je viens d'un département dans lequel on
a eu des drames récemment et dans lequel
je sais ce qu'on doit aux chasseurs pour
la protection y compris l'environnement
et donc je les pousse à discuter et à
dialoguer parfois ne pas être binaire ça
fait du bien merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité dans audition publique
merci à vous mesdames on se retrouve
bien sûr la semaine prochaine sur le cp
public sénat à 19h30 bonne semaine à
tous
[Musique]